- Today is the first
January of the new year
so, first of all, happy
new year to everyone
and welcome to this new
video on Firm Learning.
Today, I want to talk about goal-setting
on how to set goals for the new year
because I know that at the end of one year
at the start of the new,
everyone thinks about,
"What are my priorities?
What are my resolutions?
What do I want to achieve
in the next year?"
And surely this is also
what I am doing for myself
and when I set goals for myself,
I like to use the methodology of OKRs-
objectives and key results.
This is the methodology
that was first described
by Andy Grove, the legendary CEO of Intel,
also described in his book,
"High Output Management,"
that I will link also below in
case you're interested in it.
And it's a methodology
that got implemented
by most of the tech companies out there
and also more and more of
the old-economy companies
are rolling the OKR framework out as well.
OKR stands for objectives and key results.
The idea is that you do define
an objective that you want to achieve
but then also back it up
with some key results-
things that you want to see,
that you want to accomplish,
that then load into the
objective that you want to reach.
When I like to set my goals,
I like to cluster them
in three different areas.
The first is professional goals,
second sports and health goals,
and then third also personal growth goals.
So, I will now show you exactly how
I approach this goal-setting
for the new year-
what the things are that
I want to accomplish
in the next year.
And I do hope that this
serves as a motivation for you
as well for the goals that
you might set for yourself.
So, without further
ado, let's get into it.
This is my goal-setting sheet
and you see the three areas
that I set my goals in,
but let's start with
the professional goals.
And as some of you know,
I work for Munich-based proptech company
called Building Radar.
Of course, I have many goals
with Building Radar as well
but for confidentiality reasons,
let's not look into them right now.
But let's rather focus on the
other side of my profession
and as all of you know
watching this channel,
I also have this YouTube
channel Firm Learning.
For those of you who
see this the first time,
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel, I talk about
how to be successful in the
first years of your career.
I talk about slide-writing
tips, Excel advice,
other career-related topics,
consulting-related topics.
So, like and subscribe
if this is something that
you're interested in.
And how the OKR system is set up
is that you always
start with an objective.
So here, for instance, in
the first line, YouTube:
to become the leading career
and consulting creator on YouTube.
But then you always have the key results.
So, you measure this objective
by achieving these key results,
which should be objective
and measurable in the end.
So here, for instance,
how many YouTube videos I
want to create each week.
So, I want to continue to
create one quality YouTube video
every single week,
and then I also want to do a
couple of additional things.
So, to ideate and launch a new
content format for YouTube.
So, stay tuned on what
that is going to be.
I trust you will learn about it soon
over the course of the year.
And if you want to know more about
what these OKRs are all
about, how these work,
I created another video last
year about exactly this topic.
I will link it somewhere above here
so I don't need to repeat myself,
but you can just look it up
if you're interested in it.
By the way, if you do
like this Excel sheet
that I prepared to track the goals,
I will offer it for you as a
download, of course, for free.
Just check the video description
for the download link
and you will get it sent
to your personal inbox.
Overall, if I can compare these goals
to the goals that I set a year ago,
especially these numeric
ones on subscriber growth,
I must say that I
significantly under delivered
on some of them,
but on the other hand,
OKRs are supposed to be stretch goals,
so it's absolutely okay to not deliver
every single goal here.
In many ways, the last year has been
one of the most successful,
most fulfilling years
of all times for me in
many different ways.
So, definitely nothing
I can complain about.
But you see, newly added to
the sheet compared to last year
is my presence on TikTok.
So, I started with Tik
TOK in the last year.
I post the educational short-form content
and I want, of course,
to further grow in that
so if you're interested to
check out my TikTok presence,
the handle is just also firmlearning.
Check it out and let me know
what you think about it.
Last but not least is to create
a new flagship course for Firm Learning
talking about communications
and slide writing.
So, I know that I already talked about
a similar course last year.
Here, I failed, frankly,
to deliver this to you,
but now I started and I'm quite advanced
and I'm quite confident
that in Q1 at some point
you will this new course
see to be go live.
Over the course of the last year,
I created lots of corporate
training sessions-
so, training sessions
for corporate clients
on topics such as
communications, slide writing,
problem-solving skills.
And all of this content and learnings
I will combine into one new
educational flagship offering-
the communications and
slide-writing course.
It will launch soon.
I prepared a little mailing list
where if you want to learn more and join
that you can sign up.
Just check out the video description link
and I will send you an
exclusive launch offer
as soon as it goes live.
You will be the first
one hearing about it.
So, check this out.
Put your name on the list if
you're interested in that.
Overall, also reflecting
on my personal experience,
having started this YouTube
channel in January 2020,
I do think that having
side projects like this
on top of your regular job
can be quite fulfilling.
For me, it definitely
made a big difference.
There are many lots of great opportunities
that opened up only due to this
that I would never even have dreamed of
when I started all of this in early 2020.
So, think about what
could be other projects
that you would be open and willing to do
on top of your regular nine-to-five job.
If you do find the time for that
and can commit to consistently
deliver on such a project,
my experience is that good
things will likely come to you.
Next are my goals in the
health and sports section.
So here, number one for me is
to get back into the running shape.
This is one of the areas where I did
significantly under-deliver last year.
I wanted to run a marathon.
Then the marathon was canceled
due to the health situation
and this pretty much took
away all the motivation
for me to really engage in
a regular running practice.
This is one I want to
re-engage in this year,
get back into a regular running practice
and then potentially in Q3
also run a marathon once again.
And then the next point
is signing up for a gym.
So, one of the perks of
working at Building Radar
is that directly next to the office
there's a really high-quality gym
that almost all employees attend
and it's very well accepted to hit the gym
for an hour or so every single day.
So, I do want to take advantage of that,
sign up for the gym,
and probably establish a habit
of two or three times per week
going to the gym, hitting the gym,
and getting some additional
training in as well.
Last but not least, my
personal growth goals.
So, even though this is something
I did wanted to complete in the last year,
I did not complete my PhD yet.
So, one of these other things
where I did not have the
progress that I wanted to have,
but this year hopefully will be the year.
I did make some significant
progress last year.
I have now the key paper of my PhD
under review with a
pretty awesome journal.
So, let's see whether this goes through.
That would be pretty amazing.
I will let you know once this is decided.
So, making some significant
progress on the PhD,
potentially even finishing it,
would be pretty insane, pretty great.
So, fingers crossed for that.
And then I'll also have some
personal net worth goals.
So, while I would not consider
myself a frugal person,
I do like to save my money to invest it.
Also made a video about that.
I will link it somewhere above here.
Last year, I set myself the goal
of having a 50% saving rate.
This goal I did achieve,
so now I thought let's maybe
bump it up a little bit to 60%.
Let's see how well this goes.
And then, of course, I also have
some specific net worth targets.
For obvious reasons, I will
not disclose them right here.
If you want to learn more
about how I think about
this topic of tracking your net worth,
understanding a little bit better,
I will link another video above here
with a pretty cool net-worth
tracker that I developed there
and that I offer you
there also to download.
Check that out if that's
interesting to you.
I do think that tracking your net worth
can make a difference for many people.
So, I encourage you to check it out
and see whether it does
make sense for you as well.
So, of course, all of this
is just for inspiration.
I trust that your goals
will look vastly different
than those that I put
down here for myself.
What I do think though-
there's just this conscious effort
of writing down all your
goals in all these areas,
just going into you and
thinking for yourself
what actually the things are
that you want to accomplish next year-
This exercise alone will help you
to make really a big step
towards exactly these objectives.
And just by doing that,
I trust it will be
already a big step ahead
compared to many other people
are not doing these things.
I hope you found this
helpful and inspiring
for your personal goal-setting
for the new year as well.
Once again, I offer
this template that I use
to describe and track my
goals as a download for you.
You can just get it by
clicking on the link
in the video description.
Hope this is helpful.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up date on all my content.
Big thanks to all the members
who support the channel.
I actually did a couple of changes
to the membership program.
So, click the join
button to check this out,
where this is relevant to you.
My name is Heinrich.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
Looking forward to talk
to you again next week.
Until then, all the best and bye-bye.